[Applause]
well thank you so much
well it's great to see y'all
glad that we can finally do events again
that is fun
first of all just want to thank fred and
linda allen for sponsoring this event
the fsu college republicans the fsu
institute of politics law enforcement
for making sure that we can do this in
safety
and of course we have to thank the
protesters outside because
we're always happy when our fellow
americans are exercising their first
amendment rights even if they are
incoherent
so tonight we're going to talk about how
wokeness is destroying america and
here's the thing a lot of members of the
left starting to realize that wilkins is
destroying america which is why of late
you've seen some conversations about how
you're not supposed to use the term
wokeness which is weird since they made
it up
and so i'm fine with using the term
wokeness i intend on continuing to use
that word it is their fault that it
became a poisonous word not mine it's
because the idea is incredibly stupid so
the problem with wokeness is that
bottom line it promulgates lies in
particular it promulgates four sets of
lies it promulgates lies about the
nature of the united states
it promulgates lies about the nature of
inequality
responsibility and finally it
promulgates lies about the nature of
truth itself
so when it comes to claims about the
united states wokeness essentially
claims that america is fundamentally
racist and that western civilization at
root is similarly racist
in the words of critical race theory
founders richard delgado and jean
stefanczek racism is ordinary not
aberrational it's the usual way society
does business the common everyday
experience of most people of color in
this country
so the basic idea
secondarily is that because of this
racism is embedded in all of america's
institutions and that it serves
particular purposes for it to be
embedded in all of america's
institutions the reason the institutions
were created the way they were was to
embed and enshrine racism
this is the case made by the 1619
project pseudo-historian nicole hannah
jones the anti-intellectual
she says that america was truly founded
in 1619 not in 1776 because slavery not
freedom is at the heart of everything
america was is and presumably will be
into the future
now both of these claims about american
history one that america and western
civilization broadly written are just
racist and that everything about them is
racist and second that our institutions
and our deepest our most deeply held
principles were created in order to
enshrine racism both of those ideas are
just lies
racism as anyone who looks at the world
right now could note is present in every
society ever for all time
it is just an ugly part of human nature
to pretend that western civilization
broadly speaking that america in
particular have a monopoly on racism is
both historically crazy and inaccurate
today
according to max fischer in the
washington post just a few years ago
there's a study what he found is that
people were most likely to embrace a
racially diverse neighbor in the united
kingdom and its anglo-former colonies
namely the united states canada
australia new zealand and in latin
america
so all of the
countries that are typically associated
with western civilization lead to
anglo-american civilization are the
least racist countries on planet earth
not the other way around
then there's the question as to whether
the institutions of western society and
american society entrenched such racism
or whether again racism is endemic to
human beings endemic to human nature and
that the institutions that we enshrined
and that we created actually fight back
against racism
so according to the wokes
notions like meritocracy systems like
capitalism concepts like due process of
law are in and of themselves racist
this has been a case that's actually
been made by people who believe in
critical race theory all of these
systems
forward racism foment racism
now the truth is when i say those
principles you understand right off the
top that they are not just not racist
they are effectively anti-racist
there are certain rules in american
public life that have been racist
obviously
segregation was an enforced part of
american public law in many states in
the united states slavery was legal in
the united states for 80 years from the
beginning of the republic and then for
150 years before that
but to suggest that the notion of
capitalism free market capitalism is
racist is idiotic it is not true free
market capitalism is based in the notion
that each individual was created in
god's image and therefore has a right to
his or her own labor and the alien and
the alienability of that labor
the notion of a meritocracy that you
ought to rise or fall based on your
skill set based on your hard work is
patently anti-racist because you're not
using an arbitrary metric like an
immutable skin color in order to judge
whether somebody ought to benefit or not
benefit you are using something that
actually benefits other people and that
is not tied to race your merit
the concept of due process of law is
specifically anti-racist
before due process of law was extended
in the 14th amendment to black americans
this was one of the major problems in
the united states black americans were
not entitled to due process of law under
the constitution a fatal flaw in the
original constitution of the united
states that led to the civil war due
process was specifically designed in
order to enshrine individual rights
against racism
okay then wokeness makes a claim about
inequality okay so makes claims about
america american history our
institutions it also makes claims about
inequality these claims are lies
wokeness makes a very strong claim with
regard to inequality wokeness claims
that all inequality in life is evidence
of inequity
now this is a semantic trick right you
understand that they're taking the word
equality and then they're taking the
word equity and they are hoping that you
noticed that a syllable just went
missing there and that when they say
inequality and inequity what you really
think is okay well equity is a good
thing and so if something is
unequal that means it's not equity okay
these words have completely different
meanings
okay if something is unequal this does
not imply that something unfair happened
if you worked hard for your pay today
and somebody else did not work hard for
their pay today you received unequal
wages this does not mean that some deep
abiding unfairness has taken place
but nonetheless they have to make this
case that all inequality throughout
society is evidence of inequity to reach
this stunningly idiotic conclusion they
employ the following argument they begin
with all people are created equal not in
their rights all people are created
equal you are equal to the person
sitting next to you in every conceivable
way
thus if you are equal to the people
sitting next to an every conceivable way
any groups are equal in any conceivable
way because again if if you are all
exactly the same doesn't matter how i
divvy up the room any group is going to
be the same as any other group
thus all disparate results between
groups can only be due to either natural
differences or discrimination but it
can't be natural differences because
you're exactly the same as the pertinent
person sitting next to you so it must be
discrimination
right so that's the sort of idiotic
syllogistic logic that's being used here
now the problem is that pretty much
every single one of these premises is
false
now unless you think that i'm
exaggerating the case that i'm just
making up what the works that say about
this they say it right out it's not like
they're hiding the ball here ibra max
candy
who for some odd reason has been hailed
as some sort of intellectual giant when
the man has intellectual wattage that if
translated to electric
capacity might be able to toast a piece
of bread lightly
ibra max candy
argues quote as an anti-racist when i
see racial disparities i see racism any
racial disparities this means racism
this also means as the smithsonian
institute's national museum of african
american history and culture proposes
that inequality exists and thus all
racial groups struggle under white
supremacy now again every single one of
the premises that we just discussed is
false all people are not created equal
in every single way we are created equal
in the sight of god that means that we
have individual rights before god that
does not mean that you are equal to the
person sitting next to you in any sort
of capacity maybe you are maybe you
aren't
but
i would guess that in most
capacities of life you are very
different than the person who is sitting
next to you you have different skill
sets you have different innate qualities
you've grown up differently you make
different choices
secondly
if all of us are different this means
that not all groups are going to be
equal any two groups anywhere are going
to have different characteristics if i
took a line and i split this room this
half and this half there would be
different average characteristics in
this half of the room versus that half
of the room that is just a statistical
reality on average groups are different
finally differences between groups could
be due to natural differences i.e if you
take a group and they are very old
they're going to have natural
differences with a group that's very
young so for example if you if you look
at income statistics very often you'll
see certain groups compared to other
groups in terms of income well what if
the average age of one group is very
different than the average age of
another group that happens to be the
case in the united states by the way
between black and white the average age
of white americans is closer to 60. the
average age of black americans is closer
to 25
and what does that mean it means that on
a wealth level you would expect older
people to have more wealth they've had a
lifetime of accruing wealth
so you have to adjust for age if you
actually wish to even out the stats for
example
okay this is true with every group men
and women have very different
inequalities i know i hate to break that
to the left men and women very different
stuff we've known since we were small
children and then had to unlearn because
our college professors are largely
idiots
and it's also possible that there is
different decision making within groups
this is clearly true if there are many
individuals in any given group that act
differently than the individuals in
another group the averages of the
activity will be different
the lie that inequality is the result of
inequity means that the solution will be
to destroy standards
changing testing standards getting rid
of magnet schools in places like new
york because too many asian kids are
getting in and if too many asian kids
get in that means white supremacy
because if there's one thing we know
about white supremacy it is very much in
favor of asian kids
right we have to change all this in
california they're trying to do the same
thing they're suggesting that math
standards have to change because the
standards of success for math are
discriminatory i'm pretty sure the
standards for math are about as
objective as it gets right there's a
right answer in math and we can argue
with that right answer all we want but
it's not going to change the fact there
is a right answer all you're doing when
you say that people of particular races
are incapable of achieving the right
answer is you are being as racist as
david duke would be
and yet this is exactly the case that
the wokes make
there's this meme online that's been
going around this is great
comedy there's a guy named ryan long in
his comedy and there's this great video
he does where he and his friend one of
them is woke and one of them is racist
and the wolks and the racists are
exactly their best friends
they're sharing drinks together they're
giving each other hugs that's exactly
right if you take all the woke arguments
and you flip them on their head it
sounds exactly like something a white
supremacist would a white supremacist
would say
more broadly
blaming freedom of choice for disparate
group results means destroying freedom
right the idea that wokes give is that
if we are all left to our own devices
inequality will be the result thus we
must restrict activity for everyone to
achieve equal result
it also means substituting bad metrics
of success for good ones
so
for example as i've suggested there's
been a suggestion by the left by the
woke that the meritocracy is bad
now
i think the word meritocracy is a dumb
word i do it was actually coined by a
socialist in 1958 in britain the term
meritocracy was coined in order to
deride the idea that intellectual
ability and hard work are more moral
they're not right how we're born
intellectually is
not of our own making right some of us
are born smarter some of us are born
dumber really that doesn't have anything
to do with moral merit moral merits a
very different thing there are people
who are not as smart who are wonderful
people saintly people they're people who
are really smart who are terrible people
most of them are politicians right this
but the reality is that if instead of
meritocracy we used a term skills
accuracy it would make a lot more sense
as to what our society looks like namely
if you have marketable skills you will
make more money if you are more
intelligent and you work really hard you
will make more money than if you are not
as intelligent or if you don't work as
hard even if you are intelligent okay
now the good news about that is that it
has excellent externalities the skills
accuracy has externalities right if
somebody is super innovative they're
really smart they're really innovative
and they work hard if we reward them you
might think they don't deserve it you
might think well you know that teacher
down the street who works really hard
deserves it more that may be your moral
judgment but the person who's really
smart and really innovative and working
hard creates externalities like you get
cheaper goods and services better goods
and services available to more people
any system that rewards skills has
excellent externalities for third
parties it's p in any society some
people are going to be rewarded and some
people are not going to be rewarded as
much the question is what metric do you
use in order to delegate who is rewarded
and who is not
presumably as a society we would like to
reward people such that the
externalities of their activities make
our lives better that's why we reward
bill gates for creating windows that's
why we reward elon musk for making tesla
right the system rewards that labor
specifically because it makes a lot of
people it makes their lives better and
it makes their lives easier
okay wokeness also tells the third lie
and that is about the nature of
responsibility so as you would imagine
if the idea is that all inequality is
the result of inequity this means no
responsibility for anyone
wokeness lays every disparity between
underperforming groups on victimization
by the system now
that can be true right this is not to
deny that there have been cases in
american history and that there are
cases around the world right now where
some groups are not performing as well
as other groups because of
discrimination of course discrimination
is a very real thing
but
this cannot be an endless process of
redress of grievances beyond the point
where the people who sinned are now
being asked to repay because then you
end up with an endless cycle of
grievances it's one thing to say that if
i hit you with my car i ought to pay you
it's another thing to say that if i hit
you with my car and that this has
downstream effects that are negative for
your kids that four generations from now
my great great great grandchildren
should pay your great great great
grandchildren if you go back far enough
in history every single person has been
a member of a group that was victimized
and a group that was a victimizer right
we all have a wide variety of blood
types within us check 23 in me except
for elizabeth warren who's not native
american but aside from that
if you check 23andme we all have
membership to various ethnic groups in
various places on earth in various
locations
and i'm sure all of our ancestors have
suffered some discrimination rather this
is not to say that all that
discrimination is the same that is of
the same magnitude it is to say that
there is no cosmic justice that is
available whereby we calculate today
your fractional deserts for the blame of
the past and your fractional desert for
for what you deserve from everybody else
there is no way to do that that is just
not possible what we can do is look to
what individual decisions can we make
today inside a free system that make
lives better
you'll notice that when it comes to
responsibility the woke never want to
talk about it because it might actually
fix problems what they want is
deliberately designed not to make lives
better
it's designed to ignore how you make
lives better
it's designed to restructure the system
the system is bad the system must be
torn down never mind that the system has
created more prosperity and more health
and more wealth than any system in the
history of humanity bar none it has to
be torn down because it is unjust
because it is inequitable
well the reality is that if you want to
improve your life in a free country what
you need to do is start making smart and
good decisions
this game that we play or personal
decisions that could improve improve
lives are ignored
because we'd rather blame ancestry or
blame people who don't bear the
culpability for their parents or their
grandparents or their great grandparents
that game hurts everybody
we should not be teaching black children
in the united states that they are
inherently victimized because of slavery
any more than we should be teaching
jewish kids in the united states that
they are inherently victimized because
of the holocaust
some blackheads are victimized by racism
today just as some jewish kids are
victimized by anti-semitism there's
certain racism in certain policies
presumably then we call out those
policies together and we name them and
we change them
but to suggest that every single kid who
is born of a particular race is under
the thumb of a system is a lie it is not
true
and what's more it's incredibly damaging
it's incredibly damaging to our society
it's incredibly damaging to those kids
there's nothing more damaging than
telling a kid they cannot succeed in
life because the system is rigged
against them it is a lie
okay finally
wokeness lies about the nature of truth
itself
so truth is really uncomfortable it's
really ugly it makes people feel bad
i say facts don't care about your
feelings but feelings do care about the
facts and when you tell people that
certain things are just reality they get
very angry at that reality
and so we create narrative instead of
acknowledging facts we start talking
about my truth right i have to express
my truth there's no such thing as your
truth it's just your opinion and the
truth that's it
okay but the idea of my truth has become
very predominant when it comes to the
woke right my my lived experience is
what matters as opposed to say
statistical data or as opposed to the
fact that there might be an alternative
explanation for how you perceive things
in the world
okay well here are some facts these are
all very uncomfortable but these are
facts income is not primarily a function
of racial group in the united states it
is mainly a function of intelligence and
hard work this is why nigerian americans
are the most educated group in america
and asian americans are the highest
income group in america
for a white supremacist country we are
doing a terrible job at the white
supremacy
here are a few more facts
races do not commit crimes at similar
levels in fact races don't commit crimes
at all individuals commit crimes and
those individuals can be classified
theoretically by race and those numbers
might not be equivalent
people organized by race do not go to
college at similar levels they do not
have children out of wedlock at similar
levels they do not study a similar
number of hours they do not have the
same ages they don't major in the same
subjects they do not get married at
similar levels
none of this is racist this is just fact
culture and decision making can close
those gaps
we know this because these disparities
have vacillated over time
notice by the way i have not even named
any of the races i'm talking about
right because those those numbers can
change
the fact is that in the white community
the single motherhood rate used to be
about five percent today it's about 40
in the white community in the united
states
okay that is a result of a culture that
has been driven in the white community
okay those changes over time do not
suggest changes in the genetic
composition of white people
they suggest instead differences in
behavior that are inculcated by culture
here's some more uncomfortable fact men
and women are different
i know this is a tough one
they are different in terms of how they
are physically constructed they respond
differently to stimuli they are
biologically different in fact
i hazard a guess to say that the
propagation of the entire human species
is a result of the difference between
men and women i know this is
controversial stuff
but as it turns out if men and women are
not different biological categories it
makes it extraordinarily difficult for
children to be produced
there is no such thing as a menstruating
man there is no such thing as a woman
with prostate cancer these things do not
exist
anybody who tells you differently is
selling you something
but if we ignore truth in favor of woke
lies we damn to isolation everyone who
mentions truth we're not going to face
up to any of our real problems or solve
them because problems demand solutions
bitching about society doesn't demand a
solution other than tearing down all the
institutions which of course isn't a
solution it's its own set of problems
so here's the bottom line americans hate
this stuff and they are done with it
okay what we just saw in virginia is a
result of this what we just saw in new
jersey is a result of this i think that
what we've seen in florida over the past
several years is a result of this
okay last year was the year of wokeness
in which we learned that a lot of lies
about america had to be taken as truth
we had corporations pushing the idea
that the police are systemically racist
we had broad talk about defunding the
police
we heard that the cure for america's
racial division lies in more focus on
race rather than more focused on
individuals without reference to race we
learned that all of our guiding
principles had to be ditched in favor of
equity and you know what americans hate
this crap they hate it the ironic part
is that the only people in america who
don't hate this crap are
college-educated white liberals
okay minority americans are not into
this stuff
by polling data more black americans
wanted more police in their communities
not fewer police in their communities
there's a reason the hispanic vote is
breaking away from democrats right now
democrats believed that they were going
to be able to double and triple down on
the obama coalition of 2012. this
coalition of supposedly dispossessed
people accompanied by some white
liberals and this would be the going
durable coalition for all time and as it
turns out people don't like thinking of
themselves primarily as members of
arrays they're like thinking of
themselves as individuals they like to
be catered to as people who enjoy
freedom and guess what their priorities
might mirror what they see in everyday
life not the ideas of idiots who think
that the way to appeal to latino voters
is to call them latin x's
wokeness is going away the pterodactyl
and it should
it's the reason why so many people on
the left are beginning to say that
wokeness is radioactive which is a good
thing because we need two parties that
are not woke not just one party
if wokeness wins it destroys the country
if wokeness loses maybe we find a way
back thanks so much happy to take your
questions
and
as always my my rule is that if you
disagree with anything it doesn't have
to be on this could be on any topic
raise your hand you go to the front of
the line that's what makes it fun
thank you mr shapiro
ladies and gentlemen mr shapiro is happy
to take your questions now if you have a
question please line up behind the green
line by my colleague
when it's your turn come stand on the
green mark right here and i'll hold the
microphone for you
please keep questions brief and
respectful
after you finish your turn please return
down the aisle to the back
hi ben
uh thanks for doing the tomahawk chop
very epic thank you you bet you know
when people say that that's like a
racist thing i have to say if people
just went to a stadium and started
cheering for the jews you know how happy
i would be
um so my question is very quick um what
is your favorite argument for god's
existence and why
okay so my favorite argument for god's
existence is that i believe in free will
okay the reason that i think this is an
argument for god's existence is because
if you believe that human beings are
essentially just balls of meat wandering
around aimlessly in the universe the
kind of spinosa stone that thinks that
it was
moving of its own accord but actually
was thrown if you believe that and you
don't believe in free will then there's
an internal coherence and logic to it if
you believe that you have the ability to
make independent choices that you can
actually supersede your own biologic
your own biological drives and the
environment around you to any extent
even to the smallest extent this means
that you believe in something that can't
actually be proved by science but that
you are living every single day and the
notion that you have that will and not
only that you have that will but that
that will is capable of comprehending
the universe around you that your will
is sort of your ideas your ability to
comprehend the universe is a reflection
of a reality of an objective truth that
is out there that says to me that there
is a god that there's a common source
that stands behind that objective truth
and stands behind the mind that can
comprehend that truth or sort of
continent argument for the existence of
god
[Applause]
why do you believe you're right about
trans people given the american
psychological association american
medical association american
psychoanalytic association i can go on
for about five more associations
um that are very prominent and govern
the um the existing like health uh
health government or
health industries within um like the
major western countries
and all of these associations have
multiple thousands of doctors
sociologists psychologists and with phds
in their respective fields backing the
idea that sex and gender are different
effectively gaining the medical
consensus for sex and gender being two
different concepts yet you have a
different opinion okay so sex and gender
are two different concepts but gender is
tied to biology so one of the big
problems that you see in sort of the the
argument in favor of trans rights is
this notion that gender and sex are
completely separable they're not
completely separable if they are
completely separable then this means
that identifying people by their
subjective gender really has no
relevance as to whether they are male or
female male and female are biological
terms so using terminology like male and
female to describe a self-descri
self-perception of of maleness or
femaleness is sort of bizarre way of
arguing whether a thing is a man or
woman so here's my question it's an
argument that my friend matt walsh likes
to make what is a woman define what a
woman is without reference to the word
woman please
um so this is actually a logical fallacy
called a red herring you're asking me a
question in different or um in order to
actually challenge my question without
no it isn't i'm saying that it really is
not i'm saying that biology i'm agreeing
with you that the notion of gender which
is effeminateness or masculinity can be
different from biology in the sense that
biology is just pure male or pure female
but to suggest that there is such a
thing as an effeminate male is not to
suggest that an effeminate male is now a
woman
transgenderism makes the argument that
if you believe that you are a woman you
are there for a woman or if you believe
that you are a man you are there for a
man
i disagree with this there are objective
measures as to whether you're a man or a
woman there are objective measures as to
whether you are male or female you're
there there's certainly a spectrum with
regard to effeminateness versus
masculinity that's certainly true that
does not change the underlying sexual
dichotomy that is the basis for all
human reproduction
yeah you can
answer um right so this dichotomy is a
false dichotomy that isn't supported by
any of the medical associations that i
just named then let me explain medical
associations that i just named off would
actually support the idea that um
gender is biological this is something
that's completely untrue every single
like medical consensus well then i will
just say that anyone who suggests that
gender has no reference whatsoever to
biology it's not connected in any way to
biology it's just full of because
if if they see and the reason i
and
and the re and the reason that i say
then you then you class it then you
actually just disagree with medical
consensus yes i disagree yes i disagree
with the false medical consensus driven
by politically driven quote unquote
doctors if any doctor denies to me that
there is a dichotomy between male and
female a sexual dichotomy between male
and female they are ignorant and they
are letting their politics get in the
way of their science anybody who
suggests to you that there is such a
thing for example as a pregnant male is
not a doctor they are an activist
[Applause]
i'm very glad that none of these
opinions are actually accepted in
academia and haven't been for over 70
years synth is here on okay so the
notion that they haven't been accepted
for over 70 years is a bizarre one
considering they were accepted until
about five minutes ago and the basic
idea that male and female do not exist
runs counter to all mammalian biology
all of it not just human are we to
suggest that gender and and sex are
different in walruses how does this work
exactly like
are they different in bears any time you
have a any time you have all mammalian
reproduction is rooted in the idea that
there's a sexual dichotomy between male
and female to obscure that with all
sorts of semantic word games about how
you feel subjectively has no bearing on
whether male and female are categories
that exist and if you're trying to
define male and female with reference to
any subjective category that cannot be
identified by any metric whatsoever
other than how you feel today i
challenge whether that is scientific or
whether that is merely a self-perception
that is being guided by a political
agenda
i'm sorry i could spend more time on
this but we have to guess the next
question i appreciate it
[Applause]
hey bud
good to see you hey everybody here good
to see you guys too i'm glad to be here
i got in on the stand in line so i'm
really happy to be here um do you know
about the bill that republicans are
trying to pass to stop critical race
theory being taught in college um i'm
aware that there isabelle i haven't read
the text of it but go ahead
okay so in florida i think it's gonna go
oh i look sick um
so it's gonna be
decided i guess we're gonna talk about
it in like december um yeah in the new
legislative session correct yes go ahead
so as a republican being pro free speech
do you have anything to say against this
like we're really
simply just outlawing certain words to
be used in public spheres such as
education
um i feel like more republicans should
kind of seem see this as concerning you
know you guys always quote uh 18 1984 or
whatever
um you know this is like an orwellian
move isn't it so so it depends on what
level of education we're talking about
if we're talking about the idea that
critical race theory can be taught as
one of many theories on college campuses
i have no problem with it marxism is
taught as one of many theories on
college campuses if the idea is that
we're going to be teaching critical race
theory which is not
taught as one of many theories it's
taught as a framework for understanding
the world and it is a lens through which
we are to view history this is something
that the founders of critical race
theory openly acknowledge they suggest
the critical race theory has a praxis
component meaning it's a practice
component that is designed in order to
indoctrinate kids in a particular type
of thinking about how america's
institutions work do i think that the
taxpayers of the state of florida have
an obligation to subsidize the
indoctrination of their children in that
no and i think that public education as
an institution is dedicated not merely
to the idea that you send your kids to
school then the teachers dump whatever
they want on your kids i think the idea
is that these the parents delegate their
power to educate their children to the
state
via the public schools and then they
have the authority and should have the
authority to determine what framework is
being taught and the anti-american
framework of critical race theory which
is unrooted in actual history ought not
be taught in america's public schools
um
like critical race theory is literally a
footnote in my sociology class and it's
a framework if you want to take it in as
a framework listen i learned critical
race theory and i was at harvard law
school too right i mean i i in fact
whenever you talk about critical race
theory you say the right things you know
what you're talking about but because
you're a republican it's the talking
point to go against no they are i'm a
pro
free speech american so this deeply
concerns me when there are words exact
words that are being restricted
in the public sphere well that's why i
just ended up by saying marketplace of
ideas so i'm a big marketer right so i i
again i would distinguish between
marketplace of ideas in the college
realm and mark when presumably people
are old enough to actually understand
what they're talking about have open and
interesting debates about these topics
and when you're talking about
eleven-year-olds or ten-year-olds or
when you're talking about reading
ibramax kenny which is a really
dumbed-down version of critical race
theory for
five-year-olds for colleges not for
eleven-year-olds well then i'll have
colleges i'd be happy to look at the
text of the bill and determine what i
think about the bill i do think that
public schools
i'm not sure that public schools have an
obligation to teach as practical
critical race theory again i think there
are different ways that it's taught so
if we're talking about just
intersociology classes one of many
theories about american history and now
we're going to talk about how it applies
i don't really have a problem with that
being taught if we're talking about
critical race theory being taught as a
framework to view america's institutions
to the exclusion of other frameworks i
do have a problem with that
thank you
hello um so earlier on in your lecture
you were saying that
due process past the 14th amendment has
been equally distributed to all groups
across america no i said i said i didn't
say that in practice it has i said the
concept of due process is dedicated to
the proposition that people should be
treated as individuals obviously
segregation and and racism and criminal
justice up until the civil rights act
would suggest that on a practical level
it was not equally distributed obviously
okay so in idea but in practice it was
you agree that it was um
not equally distributed to all groups
across america
okay
so then wouldn't that how is that in
opposition to
um critical race theory that teaches
that these institutions have been used
to um prosecute certain groups
differently than others have been
prosecuted because that's not what
critical race theory teaches what
critical race theory teaches is that
supposedly colorblind institutions like
due process of law or cover for racism
as a as an institution due process of
law is a problem because it is not
because it is a good concept badly
applied or improperly applied it's
because it is in and of itself a
discriminatory concept right this is
what they said by capitalism also right
free market economies are inherently
discriminatory they are covers for
institutions of power that's the
critique the critique is that due
process of law in and of itself the idea
of treating people individually ignores
key components about human beings namely
how they are seen racially by other
human beings and thus due process of law
is not enough to guarantee that people
are treated equally or can be treated
equally i disagree i think due process
of law is an excellent guarantee and
straying away from that guarantee has
been the problem with regard to process
of law not the actual guarantee itself
okay
sorry my voice is a bit gone um so then
would you agree not banning critical
race theory in public inst um
like in theory that in the theory that
they are covers what would you be a
proponent of having the education that
these institutions have been used to
attack other minority groups across
america and that it has had historic um
scars that are still um rep that um we
still see today so i wouldn't say that
the institutions have been used to abuse
due pro i wouldn't say due process of
law has been used to abuse minorities i
would say that people have refused to
implement due process of law because
they wanted to abuse minorities of
course and of course you'd have to teach
about that i mean that's the entire
history of segregation and the
subjugation of black americans up to the
civil rights act for sure of course and
and this is why it's such a lie when
people say that if you don't want to
teach critical race theory you don't
want to teach history i'm fine with
teaching every ugly part of american
history what i'm not fine with is the
idea that the foundational ideas of the
united states of america the notion that
we are created equal before god with
certain inalienable rights and the
government was instituted in order to
protect these rights i disagree with the
fundamental idea that these were a cover
for power designed in order to subjugate
black americans i think that's a lie and
i think it's deleterious to teach that
to kids
[Applause]
right here okay so um i don't want to
misinterpret your position but it's your
belief tell me if i'm right or wrong
about this okay um it's your belief that
america is fundamentally a skillsocracy
as you call it as opposed to a
meritocracy correct
yes
okay
then how because i don't connect moral
merit with with intellect people are
born yeah yeah okay
nice um that's good uh the um my
question is how do you explain the fact
that the vast majority of american
inequality is caused by the people who
you know the neighborhoods you grew up
in the amount of wealth your parents
have and thousands and thousands and
thousands of other whether you believe
that race is involved or not but
thousands of other non-skill based
factors
um that are integral to moving head in
the american system so i don't think
that that's true primarily what i think
is that all of those things have an
impact on the skills that manifest in
the marketplace
no question but what the market measures
is is at the point of the skills it's
not measure if there's a skilled person
who's coming from an impoverished
background where there's a lot of single
motherhood in crime for example and that
person has high skills that person is
going to do fine
okay but the problem is that all of
those things can contribute to a lack of
skills
right this is part of my argument and
the only way to to actually alleviate
that problem is to change the cultural
milieu that makes it very difficult for
people to achieve a certain level of
skills in particular communities
single motherhood makes it very
difficult for example for kids to grow
up in an environment where they have a
solid family home where they're studying
a lot at home where education is is of
primary value as opposed to just getting
through the day crime free for example
and without being victimized by
neighbors high crime areas right all of
these things are things that we can
alleviate and i think that we should
alleviate them these are real problems
to people fully developing their skills
the point that i'm making is that the
system of economics is not punishing
people for their upbringing it's
punishing them for lack of skills which
may in fact be an effect of their
upbringing
right but that but that does not mean
that primarily these skills accuracy is
punishing people for their for for their
environment or for their race it is
punishing them for the fact that when it
comes time for them to go to the job
market they don't have the same skills
as the person next to them so the
question becomes not how do we get rid
of the skills accuracy the question
becomes how do we get rid of the
obstacles to people who could be more
skilled becoming more skilled
and that means creating cultural
institutions that matter it means
creating communities it means trying to
ensure that people have a father and a
mother in the home trying to make sure
that people can live in safe
neighborhoods where there are thriving
communities where there are jobs
available
right that would that would effectuate a
better opportunity set to enter the
skillsocracy but what i see is people
attacking the distribution of reward at
the skills level as opposed to attacking
the underlying problem which creates a
lot of the inequalities you're talking
about
[Applause]
yeah so i was wondering you so you
believe that um things like single
motherhood things like growing up in
high crime areas are inherently cultural
rather than to do with any institutions
or any inequalities uh that are part of
american society institutionally no i
think that history has a long tail but i
think that the only way that you fix
that is by changing the incentive
structure for individuals right now
so i think that you can blame the the
the amount of crime in a particular
community on a long history of
disinvestments in that community 50 60
years ago i don't think it's going to
change a damn thing and i don't think
pouring money into the community is
necessarily the solution i think if
you're looking at high crime levels i
think the best solution is you need more
cops on the ground to stop the crime
this is what's going to allow people to
invest in the area and provide more jobs
and i think that trying to spend all of
your time the question is are we trying
to
are we trying to diagnose a problem that
is solvable or are we trying to just
describe the history of the problem if
we want to describe the history of the
problem that's fine but using that as a
substitute for a practical solutions
based approach to problems is a
political mistake one is the study of
historians the other is the study of
politicians and political actors that
ought to actually be applied in real
life
so when you have a solution like
affirmative action or you have a
solution like uh benefiting people from
lower income communities and i know
obviously there's a difference between
affirmative action on the racial level
and affirmative reaction on the economic
level you think that government policy
should have no role in uh in alleviating
those inequalities even though
government policy purportedly in the
past even though i would argue currently
created those inequalities in the first
place i think that any time the
government attempts to remedy past
discrimination by the use of current
discrimination all they are doing is
effectuating discrimination and
undermining the skills accuracy that
allows for positive externalities yes
[Applause]
[Music]
hi ben how are you
doing okay how are you great um
how come you claim to be five nine even
though you're like five five
i don't know how tall are
you you're five nine i'm actually fine
okay come over here let's see
[Applause]
hmm
i'll be honest i planned it i'm waiting
years to do that
hi how are you um my question is
regarding two very high profile court
cases going on right now the uh ahmed
arbury trials and the kyle ridden house
trials and my question is
what do you believe would be the outcome
of these trials and why okay so i think
that there's what will happen what
should happen i'm not going to try and
predict what will happen because he
cannot predict what juries are going to
do
what should happen written how should be
acquitted he clearly acted in self
defense
that doesn't mean that i would send my
17 year old over to kenosha wisconsin in
order to protect property and provide
medical aid to people but it does mean
that the shootings that he committed
were in self-defense the evidence is
pretty much as clear as day on that one
uh and uh the prosecutor has no case and
frankly he's making a fool of himself he
looks like that as a law degree for
turning in the tops of cracker jack
boxes um
in the arbory case the the main question
in the arbory case is going to come down
to legally speaking whether the whether
the mcdaniels who are the the defendants
in this particular case whether they had
the capacity under the citizens arrest
law of georgia to arrest our birds there
was some testimony last week that a
couple of weeks before they went after
arbory
and they were they went to this house
that arbory had been allegedly inside of
this this construction site and tools
had been stolen from there and all this
they went there with a local cop
apparently and the local cop was
speaking to them about how there was
somebody who looked exactly like our
bury who'd been inside stealing things
right and so what this does it provides
the predicate for the notion they have
to that if they get a call that somebody
is stealing things and that person
matches arbori's description
and and the cop in the tape says it's
possible he's stealing things it could
be a misdemeanor it could be a felony
once it's a felony you can effectuate a
citizen's arrest so the question is
going to be whether that citizen's
arrest was lawful or not the attempted
citizens arrest because once you get
down to the the end of it right the end
of it where they they're road blocking
him and they're trying to keep him from
running away an arbory runs between the
cars now you essentially have a case of
almost mutual self-defense right it's
actually really a terrible case in which
arberry sees these guys chasing him in
trucks
why is he going to pull over right and
so he tries to run
he goes for the gun they shoot him so
from their perspective they're trying to
give the citizens a arrest they have to
shoot him in self-defense from his
perspective he's trying to run away and
they're blocking him and trying to
falsely imprison him and so he's acting
in self-defense so the only way to solve
that legal conundrum is whether they
were in fact
under the belief that they were
attempting to arrest him citizens arrest
and they had good cause like uh it has
to be by the preponderance of the
evidence like 51 49 standard if they had
probably if they had um a 51 to 49
probability of the evidence that he was
committing a felony and that they could
arrest him
then they could be acquitted so that's
the legal issue that's what it's going
to come down to
considering that citizen's arrest is a
widely outdated law do you consider that
it should be reformed
um you know it's it's difficult to
reform citizens arrest because again
they're they're just so many areas where
the cops are not available i mean what i
would like is to make it so that
citizen's arrest is not something that
anybody really wants to do because the
cops are so available that you just call
them
right and by the way this is what
happens in
in in low crime
high income areas frankly there are a
lot of cops available there's a lot of
security you don't see a lot of people
running around trying to effectuate
citizens arrests in those areas you
typically have somebody calling a police
officer
and uh sorry one last question is do you
believe that rittenhouse traveled to
kenosha with the intent of stirring
trouble or not
um i think that by the available
evidence he went there with the intent
of providing medical aid and brought the
gun because he thought the trouble was
might break out or could break out i
don't think that he went there to shoot
anybody if that's the question and i
think the prosecution's case that he
went there to shoot somebody is
undermined by pretty much every single
fact on the ground including his own
behavior that night
[Applause]
hi ben how you doing okay how are you
i'm good um so in our country we have a
lot of billionaires we have a lot of
companies that are worth billions of
dollars it's a great country sure
so so tesla uses lithium mines in africa
where children are employed uh they're
paid very little amounts of money
they're starving
nike uses children in asia where they're
working with textiles and they are
injured frequently these are all
dangerous conditions uh all these
companies all these billionaire
billionaire companies
have these similar like problems at the
bottom ring
do you think that
the do you think that that's
exploitation do you think that
exploitation is a problem and do you
think that your idea of free market
capitalism has an answer for
exploitation
so
so i think that every economic system
has a problem of exploitation if it's
not bound by certain levels of morality
right socialism has a level of
exploitation too which you see in the
soviet union for example you can treat
workers as chattel and you can treat
them as trash and you can force them
into doing jobs they don't want to go
log them so any system of economics that
that relies on on force is a form of
exploitation i would say that the
problem that you see with regard to
china is not per se free markets it's
the fact that the chinese government is
willing to allow its own citizens to be
used as child labor and the fact that
there is no governance structure in
africa at all to protect children if
what you're saying about tesla is true
i'm going to assume that it is i don't
know enough about the issue
so assuming that that is the case
there's nothing in free market
capitalism that
prohibits people who are incapable of
making decisions for themselves
from being exploited that's true right i
mean if you can find somebody who's
particularly true with child labor
children are not capable of consent if
children are incapable of consent then
free marketing conditions should not
prevail and there should be laws on the
books that prevent companies from
actually using that sorts of labor we've
had child labor laws in the united
states for quite a while and i agree
with those
so but that's not to suggest that any
other economic system wouldn't be
similarly prone to exactly the same
kinds of problem as long as you are
saying that that exploitation is simply
a function of economic growth
or even economic distribution right
they're almost two separate issues so
one is an issue of morality immoral
people can use any system in order to
harm other people and particularly
children and people who can't protect
themselves
the case that socialism makes is that
people who are fully capable of consent
are also exploited and that i think is a
lie
well do you do you think that
um
i apologize oh no worries i just tripped
up but
um
yeah i'm sorry that's okay i mean i
think the the broader point that i'm
making is that when it comes to sorry
did you remember so yeah so would you be
in favor of legislation here in the
united states that prevents billionaire
companies and multi-billion dollar
companies from using exploitation around
the world uh depending on what we are
defining as exploitation sure i mean if
we're talking about like forcing small
children to make nike shoes absolutely
yes child labor yes
yes okay well and by the way we're in
agreement and by the way we're in
agreement yeah and and by the way i
would agree with with a united states
policy of tariffing any company abroad
that also uses similar levels of labor
because the big problem is that the
reason companies in the united states
presumably do that sort of stuff is in
order to compete with companies abroad
that are using exactly that sort of
labor so punishing those companies
abroad from doing that would also be a
way of preventing them from entering
american markets and undercutting
companies that are now undergoing the
higher labor cost of having to not use
small children to make shoes
yeah
all right uh hello i just wanted to ask
so i want to bring up the fact that you
talked about individuals and everything
and i wanted to bring up a few examples
like for example like covid and like say
like the 2008 financial collapse and
even like the 1994 crime bill and things
like that those have definitely effects
on big groups and especially like the
black community and everything like
after the 2008 uh financial collapse
not many people got you know
like i wouldn't say accused but
convicted for example not many people on
wall street the individuals who did
profit a lot from those things
but millions of people were kicked out
of their homes and everything and you
talk about like
us things like these being or america
being you know based on individuals and
individuals wanting to achieve different
things but in reality
a lot of like people are affected by
their societal factors they know their
environment and everything so i want to
get your answer on that and like how
these negative effects
you know affect the majority of people
but a pause the positives the money
gains you know the wall street things
not many of the working-class people in
tallahassee for example feel that you
know not many people in tallahassee felt
the uh after covid or during covid you
know the stock market jumps the average
employer just saw a bunch of just empty
you know
employment you know options and low
wages and everything still and the same
old same old so well i mean okay so i
think that the fundamental idea with
regard to it's almost two separate
questions and so i'm going to take them
one at a time the reason i'm separating
the questions is because when it comes
to corporate bailouts for example i'm
sure you and i agree i don't think that
any of those corporations should have
been bailed out i think that if you
engage in the moral hazard of wrecking
your own company i don't see why i'm
supposed to pay for that or you're
supposed to pay for that
in a free market system you're supposed
to bear the consequences of the risks
that you take i think that's true across
the board and i think that whether
you're a big rich guy on wall street and
you lose your entire company or whether
you're a guy who took out a loan that
you couldn't afford on your house if you
take out too much
that is as i
am constantly representing a you problem
if you take a risk and then you bear the
consequence of that risk that's no one's
fault but your own and anybody who comes
in to bail you out from that
particularly if you're talking about
like billions of dollars in order to
prop up a particular lifestyle that's a
huge mistake and it's a huge problem and
i totally agree with that
and um for example with that like
you know we in america we do bail these
people out you know our capitalist
system does not it's not capitalism
that's cronyism definitely yeah people
say that but no but it's true it's
nobody we do bail these people out right
i'm just saying that that's not
capitalism that's actually closer to
corporatism which is the government
being in control of the economy
essentially i mean where where is who's
bailing them out i mean are they bailing
them out the government is bailing it
definitely the government and for
example we don't get these similar
bailouts
for regular people like for example joe
biden was you know promoting just two
thousand dollars you know we're fighting
for scraps i want to understand like
where does that come from like why are
we so you know willing to get i mean the
united states does spend literally
trillions of dollars on social welfare
programs the notion the united states
has no social safety net at all is not
true the united states spends
per citizen
tens of thousands of dollars on on
social welfare benefits ranging from
medicaid to food stamps to
unemployment insurance to a wide variety
of programs the notion that we're wildly
out of line with europe is just not
borne out by the statistical facts
actually it's kind of an american myth
that we tell ourselves that we don't
spend any money on this sort of stuff
it's not true since the beginning of the
war on poverty we spent something like
22 trillion dollars on various social
programs and essentially the same number
of people live underneath the poverty
line okay and then last question so we
have this uh infrastructure bill going
through and you see people like joe
manchin you know arguing over
you know what is it five billion dollars
in regards to it or just you know just a
little price difference for example
over the past 20 years we've been
fighting wars in afghanistan and we
spent trillions and billions of dollars
and you have these politicians saying
that these infrastructure bills that
will help us
on our domestic front
these small price changes are going to
have dramatic effects on you know our
future and our children and that's why
they you know the republican party they
definitely you know go for austerity and
those you know factors so the wars to
take an example the wars in iraq and
afghanistan were expensive they cost
grand total somewhere between three and
four trillion dollars last i checked the
united states spends about four trillion
dollars in budget every single year we
spend about seven trillion dollars last
year that's every year right yeah i just
want to know what that what that means
for the future of our children if we're
willing to spend that much on war like
what does that mean in regards to you
know these infrastructure bills us
fighting over these small amounts
we're not really fighting over small
amounts these are very large amounts of
money the entire american budget 40
years ago was not nearly as much as one
of these infrastructure bills i mean 20
years ago it wasn't and just go back and
look at the budgeting so we're spending
unsustainable amounts of money on nearly
everything in american life to point out
defense spending as opposed to what
really constitutes the vast bulk of our
budget which is everything else defense
spending is a percentage of the american
budget is something like 20 25 of the
american budget i think it's even that
high that that is not the chief driver
of systemic
spending problems in the united states
it's these it's it's massive mandatory
spending programs i i have to ask you a
question were you the guy before who i
saw a picture of holding uh the very
creative flag
of us guess who was yeah dude i just i
gotta ask you like i
lenin and stalin really yeah definitely
landon and sullivan he's just
stalin stalin definitely due to world
war ii you know i mean there's an
exploitation of people i mean stalin i
mean we do a lot of that in america too
i live in tallahassee there's a lot of
exploitation i used to work at a lot of
places and there's a lot of poor people
though
we have prisons in america too we have
where you want to be like three million
people murdered by stalin like really
really if you're gonna if you're gonna
go marxist then please find a better
marxist to emulate than lenin or stalin
mass murderers
soviet union the soviet union during
world war ii
saved the world i would say that uh if
it not been for style in world war ii
never would have started because it was
the molotov ribbon trop pack that
allowed the nazi germans to believe that
they could invade eastern europe
[Music]
this will be the last question that mr
shapiro takes for the evening
that's a lot of pressure um
my name is andrew
um and uh i used to i was introduced to
you by the michael knowles book uh
reasons to vote for democrats
your quote that said thorough at the top
and it was a blank book
i don't know if anyone was
familiar with that book um
but um
i uh
my question is um about uh
it's like
in in the way that like the the things
that you're saying about
um
certain you know things being done with
hard work seeing things being done with
intellect um
as kind of like a
you know a slippery slope to two more
right like you know
racist things or like white supremacist
things
um the question is like a fsu specific
question about
um
what your thoughts are about the
difference between
canceling someone for what they believe
and accountability
in a position where they should have
accountability um specifically jack
denton
who is uh was an fsu i believe senate
person but he was basically he had um
sorry
i should be more knowledgeable about
this but um
and i really don't want to be the the
college student destroyed by ben shapiro
but um
but the question is basically he was a
he was an fsu student that um had
anti-blm anti-uh transgender uh comments
in um
uh catholic group that he had the
facebook group or something if someone
wants to crack me on that they can but
agree agreement gotcha different
application
um
but the question is basically uh what
are your thoughts on that
you know
i mean so so my my basic view of council
culture i won't comment on a specific
case because i really don't know the
facts of the case but my general
thoughts on cancel culture versus what
they call accountability culture is you
get to hold somebody accountable for a
thing that they do in the space where
they do it what i mean by that is i
speak on politics if i say something bad
about politics you cannot listen to my
show you can say that then i'm a bad man
and you should and you can come after me
and you can tell people not to listen to
me and all of that if you go after my
advertisers who are advertising on a
wide variety of programs then that is an
attempt to cancel as opposed to an
attempt to to hold accountable because
the person that you're actually
attempting to hold accountable is not me
you're attempting to go after
advertisers who have had nothing to say
about any of that my advertisers i
assume disagree with a lot of what i say
just because they advertise on the
program does not mean that they approve
of everything i say any more than they
agree with everything on msnbc if they
advertise on both of us um this this
holds true across
i would say industry so you see you'll
see a plumber and a plumber has some
sort of bad thing on a facebook page and
the idea is that you can no longer use
this plumber because what was on their
facebook page that they were talking
about politics that seems very silly to
me if you can unclog my toilet i'll use
you as the plumber these two things have
nothing whatsoever to do with each other
if it impacts your job performance
that's accountability culture if it
impacts not your job performance you
just impact sort of your public
perception that seems a lot more like
cancel culture to me
as a member of student government do you
think that he should be held accountable
to those beliefs i mean it depends who's
holding him accountable in other words
was he you'll have to tell me the story
did it was he dumped by the school from
his position in the student senate or
did people just not elect him in the
future it was a vote of no confidence
from the um student government i mean i
i can say whether i disagree or agree
with that but i can also say that if a
student government votes that they don't
want somebody else in student government
because of something that they've said
politically then
i i can think that they are are being
censorious i'm not sure that that counts
as formal cancel culture in the sense
that they're being cancelled for
something that that is outside the
purview of which they're they're
normally speaking uh but i can still
think that the people are doing it are
jackasses i don't know what he said
so both of those things can be true one
sometimes accountability culture as it's
called can also be misused it's not like
a hard divide between accountability
culture is good and canceled culture is
universally bad right i could probably
think of hypothetical scenarios where
that's not true
well thank you guys so much i really
appreciate the time it's great to see
you